all right we are close enough to noon to
go live i've already got some questions
waiting for me so this is the
ama session for june 2022 i will answer
as many questions as i can get to
if you've got questions you know you
want to get them in early you only need
to ask them once because asking them
multiple times doesn't get you your
question answered and i will get to as
many of these as i possibly can
um all right so
this is good because i i ended up having
to like you know post this thing about
youtube scrubbing questions maybe
they're not doing that anymore catholic
based asked a question a little while
ago before the session began
what comes first metaphysics or
epistemology and the answer is neither
um
you know you can find people who are
going to say we must begin with this
basis over here in philosophy
but that's their way of understanding
philosophy so you know some people think
we need to begin with metaphysics as the
first thing that we have to get down
other people epistemology you know
there's kind of a modern turn towards
that some people say ethics some people
say
philosophical anthropology there is no
consensus about this and i kind of think
that
there's a good reason for that namely
that we can begin from all sorts of
different
uh places
and you know the key is not to figure
out where to begin or what comes first
the key is to do your
work in kind of a attentive thoughtful
comprehensive way
and to keep on you know grinding away at
it
i think that people who assume that that
philosophy
has some sort of like
method or cannon or basis that's a
one-time fixed and for all you want to
stay away from those people if you want
to actually make some real progress in
the discipline
all right second question
from oldies what do you think of
bertrand russell and why i think
bertrand russell is kind of third rate
which is not bad you know i mean a
third-rate philosopher is better than a
10th rate philosopher and i don't have
criterion for what counts as first rate
or second rate or third rate so don't
bother asking about that it's just sort
of a subjective determination i think
that you know russell is
an interesting philosopher it's kind of
unfortunate that
many people trained in analytic
philosophy don't read the early canon of
analytic philosophy anymore because
there's a lot of really interesting
stuff in there with russell and moore
and wittgenstein and wisdom and all
these other people air as well is kind
of interesting and people can be
interesting and have you know things
that are well worth looking at and still
be completely wrong you know about stuff
just like hobbes and descartes and hume
are in their own ways right
russell is a terrible historian
actually he's not a terrible historian
he's a great storyteller he's great at
the narrative structure it's unfortunate
that a lot of the stuff that he says
about different philosophers you're
getting russell's take rather than
a you know a better scholarly take on
them so i wouldn't i wouldn't use his
history of philosophy for anything but
he's you know he's
worth reading you know
galen and says glad to see you're
feeling better from covid um yeah i'm
feeling better except for the fatigue i
did a video about that it's going to
force some
changes probably in work uh
load and priorities and lifestyle you
said lev chest off is a funny writer
other than kierkegaard and plato who are
some other philosophers you think are
funny that's a great question
epictetus is funny as hell um you know
you look at the ways in which he talks
with other people in his discourses
people very he's a guy who's often
speaking truth to power you know
um you look at like how he
talks to
this guy who's you know kind of high
official
and gets into a shouting match in the
theater with the audience who he favors
one comedian they favor another an
epictetus is basically if you read
between the lines you say what in the
hell is wrong with you buddy you know
and then he gives him some some useful
reframing advice so epictetus is very
funny you know the cynics themselves are
funny the ones that that we have bits
and pieces of
um
augustine you know makes some jokes here
and there
um
you know i think that uh there's a lot
of like little quips and witticisms in a
lot of philosophers somebody else who's
um kind of you know around the same time
and uh within the same spectrum you
could say as uh
stuff is miguel de una muno and he's he
can be kind of funny at times as well
there's a lot of philosophers in the
present who can be quite funny and have
you know good jokes here and there
including aleister mcintyre um
he's got a very very dry sense of humor
but you know google
benedict option
mcintyre
and you'll see him talking about
rodriguez
terrible book the benedict option
and saying how uh
drayer and all these other you know
conservatives have basically you know
misappropriated what what mcintyre had
to say and how he dissociates himself
from it is is quite good
um
all right let's see what else we've got
elijah in what way might blondel's
ontology and logic be lacking off-base
or untenable
are there major works you would put him
in dialogue with to effectively address
these issues for example anselm of the
stoic so not i wouldn't put him in in
dialogue with those i would say that um
i don't think that blondel's ontology
and logic are lacking
for those who don't understand the very
abstruse context here
um blondel actually developed something
called the the you know um
metaphysics of of charity and the
metaphysics of insufficiency and he also
develops something that he calls um you
know a concrete logic and i don't think
that his stuff is problematic at all um
i think that it's it's great stuff to
study i wish he'd done more of it and
developed it further
and i would say that the thinkers that
you want to put him into contact with
would be those who in the 20th century
really focused on the recovery
of the
dialectical
slash topical slash rhetorical tradition
like ernesto gracie who
actually came to blondel as sort of an
emissary from heidegger uh
giving him a message about how much
heidegger liked his his stuff
grassy was a recoverer of that tradition
kim perlman uh you know with his new
rhetoric is another example of that i
would say those are some of the people
to bring him into contact with um
there's you know there's an entire
tradition there that's going back to
aristotle and cicero and hitting on vico
along the way and stuff like that so
all right uh robert connor thoughts on
the current situation of the church in
the sonatal way
um i don't know what the sonata way is
supposed to mean so i'm not going to say
anything about that current situation of
the church is the church isn't like it
always is
in as big of a mess as it has been at
any given time if you study church
history you know that things are not
there's never a you know like the ideal
age when everything was great and
everybody was you know in agreement and
everybody was a good person you even
read the book of acts they had problems
back then and why did paul write so many
letters because people were messing up
you know and why do we have all these
church fathers saying all these
interesting things because people were
messing up as well you know
um i would say that you know the if
we're talking about the the catholic
church i mean we can say similar things
about the protestant church is like i
mean look at the southern baptist
convention and what a
hot mess they have turned themselves
into right
but you know i would say that
a lot of the church authorities um have
effectively lost
you could say lost the the confidence of
the
the people um in part through covering
up scandals and focusing more on you
know keeping things nice and orderly and
not on being pastors of of christ you
know
um and this is a perennial problem
there's there's always reforms needed um
not as not as if they aren't equally a
mess in
the eastern churches or in the
protestant churches or new religious
movements as well
and not as if it's not a problem in
other religions
as well and in anti-religious or
non-religious movements too so
all right um
dino says i know this must be a weird
question but are there any works on
philosophy of prayer what prayer is
yeah there's lots of things i think you
can google that it's something that gets
discussed quite a lot in the philosophy
of religion and there's like authors
that you could like go to i mean james's
varieties of religious experience or
kierkegaard's texts
saint anselm himself
effectively carried out a revolution in
prayer in the 11th century
if you
just get his book you know prayers and
meditations translated by benedict award
i think there may be a new
uh translation out there of those
there's a nice forward in there by by
her great benedictine thinker herself
and uh these amazing rhetorically
constructed
prayers that lead you into a sort of
contact with uh you know god and the
saints um so there's lots and lots of
material out there that that you could
study um i'm sure there's a ton of stuff
in the like low church protestant
evangelical
um
you know
philosophical traditions but i don't i
don't really know it i can tell you this
um one place where you could go is
looking at the wesleyan tradition
they are very interested in what goes on
in prayer so there's lots of lots of
places you could you could go with that
um
son say love your work the camera is
looking great
this is just my my
camera for my big mac
this is actually quite an old computer i
think we bought this maybe in
2013
or so so it's you know coming up to its
10-year
anniversary i'm thankful that it's still
working well you know
because computers don't always last that
long uh erickson thoughts on the
philosophy of logic and your position in
this topic i don't have a position in
the in this topic
um philosophy of logic
what we're talking about there would be
sort of instead of just logic as a
discipline
a
meta uh look at what logic is i you know
i mentioned that you know maurice
blondell has writings on this
um
so does you know
for that matter so does heidegger uh
heidegger
actually has a lot of interesting things
to say about logic hegel of course has
two different you know the science of
logic and the encyclopedia logic and
there's benedict croce and there's all
sorts of people out there john stuart
mill has some really interesting things
to say about it but you know you got to
kind of dig around in the literature i
don't know what the current up-to-date
you know
uh philosophy of logic stuff would be
uh in the present because that's not
really an area
for me
all right jb nice to see you here
glad to hear you're feeling better
please be careful and take it easy
people can get messed up jumping back
into it after a recovery yeah so that is
that is actually good advice um
those of you who don't know the context
of this i wound up with covid in late
april
and you know i didn't have to get
hospitalized thank god and i had the
omicron variant that doesn't like you
know go after your lungs and it didn't
go after my brain thank god because i
got to make a living with it
but it did you know put me down for for
quite a while it was it was rough um
kovid we're learning
not only does its own you know little
dance routine on you it's it's also like
a guy who walks around and turns up
switches here and there so you know the
chronic pain that i have in joints and
stuff like that turned that knob up to
seven sometimes up to ten
i've had lyme's disease twice and i've
had uh mononucleosis
in the past and we know that um
there's inner you know covid kind of
affects those as well so it was it was
rough going and i you know i had to
finish up the semester
obviously i couldn't film so i did other
stuff
and then you know
you get behind on work and you're like i
got to get caught up and i'd like to get
back to the gym and um on the one hand
you know you got to take it easy and and
make sure you're getting enough rest on
the other hand i still have
fatigue just about every single day that
hits and when it hits it's like a
curtain coming down you know i can do
some things like
you know when we saw primus at a con
concert just a couple days ago
i could sit there and watch them you
know and clap and stuff like that and
even get up and dance a bit but if you'd
asked me to like talk about
or something at the concert that wasn't
going to be happening
and so you know
i'm learning i'm the kind of person
who's been hard driving for decades and
i'm learning i gotta i gotta take it
easy like jb is saying here so
all right bill
bob baggins what are your thoughts on
immortality specifically immortality
through staying alive considering
humanity is living longer
well we're living longer uh in some
places i mean
there's other places where life
expectancy is slowly
going down think about russia
particularly for for men i mean now one
main source of that is is hardcore
alcoholism uh so if you cut that out of
your life maybe you'll live longer but
you know it's not as if life expectancy
is just a
guaranteed that it's just gonna keep
getting longer and longer
i mean we might get up to like 120 or
140
through you know medical advances and
stuff like that provided we don't burn
up the planet or
wind up in in horrible wars caused by
global displacements because of climate
change so a lot of this is very
contingent right
but even if you live to 120 you're still
going to die that's not immortality
that's just extended life
if we want to talk about immortality and
we want to
not think about it in a you know
religious
sort of way
uh assuming that there's something like
a soul that that survives
um then we got to think about
other
physical ways in which us
who we are
would somehow be preserved and a lot of
that's just sci-fi you know there's a
lot of cool proposals out there there's
a lot of optimism about uploading
yourself to the cloud or things like
that but that's just sci-fi it's not
it's not like
um it's gonna happen uh right away
and there's all sorts of you know
interesting metaphysical and
epistemological and anthropological
problems that we have to solve like well
is that actually me that that thing that
you claim is my brain scans you know and
my personality uploaded in a computer or
you know
there's a lot anyway there's a lot of
moving parts to this so um i don't maybe
you're asking me about sort of like
moral questions when it comes to it
i don't have a problem with people
wanting to be
immortal but i think a lot of people
want to be immortal and irresponsible
ways right they're like i want to be
immortal and i want to be like in a
video game where everybody else is an
npc and i can do whatever hell i want
with them
that would be a problem right
or i want to be immortal but i don't
care how much energy has to be consumed
to keep me immortal you know
depriving uh other people of of
those resources i think that's
problematic too
jeremy thoughts on theories of truth and
what is your position if you have one
i'm a pluralist um i think that we
have a lot of different perspectives on
truth i won't call all of them theories
and actually i'm going to be having a
book uh
review video coming out very soon on
simon blackburn's
on truth which i
you know
qualifiedly
endorse i think it's got a book with a
lot a lot of problems to it
you know we have a lot of different
theories of truth that we talk about in
intro to philosophy classes like
correspondence coherence pragmatic
deflationist you know
but those don't adequately capture what
classic philosophers have actually had
to say about the nature of truth
aquinas is not simply a
correspondence theorist hegel definitely
isn't just a coherence theorist right
anselm has an entire book called on
truth in which he talks about not only
truth in
thought and expression but also in the
nature of things in the will in action
how actions themselves can signify
um
and very little of the contemporary
discourses about truth take that sort of
thing into
account and i think it's important to
to have a sort of wide net i think that
we need we have a have to have a toolbox
that's got a lot of different
perspectives
and theories in it there's some cases
where you know maybe we need something
like um you know adequacio between uh
language and and things or thought and
things
maybe there's other cases where we
really do need to think about
practical truth as aristotle discusses
it in the nick of mccain ethics book six
which would be similar to what what
anselm is talking about in on truth uh
chapters
uh
what
three four
some of the later chapters as well
definitely 12 right
so i think that you know long story
short
might be a bit of an unsatisfying answer
we really do need multiple theories or
perspectives on on truth
made of clay how is ontology related to
modern modern psychotherapy i'll just
answer this right off the bat depends on
which ontology which modern
psychotherapy it's not as if there's a
thing out there called ontology or
anything out there called psychotherapy
there's different kinds of psychotherapy
there's different approaches the same
you know
modality may be used by two different
people in different ways
and you know ontology that it depends on
what you mean by that too right there's
different meanings to these terms there
is no simple relation between them
like that
now you say it seems like ontology is
dismissed and therapists only seem to
care about the tried and true method
without going deeper
totally depends on the therapist i mean
i work with
psychotherapists who are very interested
not only in ontology but also in ethics
and you know epistemology and and other
things as well but they're not the usual
psychotherapist these are people who
sought me out and said i need to bring
in a philosopher to help me you know
shore up what i'm what i'm doing
um
[Music]
i mean part of it could also be
a language choice if you go in and
you're like hey i want to talk about
ontology with you and the therapist is
like what the hell was that
or they they got some weird
you know whacked out version of it back
when they were an undergraduate maybe
they're like well i don't want to talk
about that i want to talk about your
your treatment plan instead
but if you can relate to them and say
well listen a treatment plan is making
some ontological assumptions or maybe
don't call it ontology maybe call it
metaphysics or maybe you don't even need
to use those words
then you can perhaps open up a dialogue
with them you know it really depends on
your your terminology choice
uh ridicule any advice or reading
recommendations for struggling with a
longing for past loves or just fighting
to try to tame my desires in general as
a young person so two totally different
uh
topics
um yeah i mean i would say
good literature is is kind of helpful
with that it's not going to give you
like a blueprint but you get to read
about
other people's struggles and maybe you
know say holy [ __ ] somebody back a
hundred years ago was feeling the same
way that i was
so you know that that can be quite
helpful and it doesn't necessarily have
to be that far back
good literature from the present can be
can be doing that too i mean just think
about
if you haven't read
octavia butler's parables parable of the
sower parable of the talents
her main character the well a main
character in it
loses her great love
um in the middle of you know kind of a
catastrophe
and also loses their child too um
in in kind of a an interesting way
and you could read that and be like well
not all of this applies to me but you
know some of this is kind of similar i
mean i get a lot out of reading
rainer maria rilkes poems and letters
and and stuff like that i i actually
ordered a facing
german english version of the duneo
elegies
because i want to
re-read them and have the german at my
disposal
and think about uh my lost sassy cat who
isn't that's not a romantic relationship
but
it's probably one of the closest
relationships i have had in my lifetime
certainly the closest relationship with
an
animal a non-human animal that i've had
and i want to think about her you know
existing
past death
and you know the difference between
death and life and all that sort of
stuff that can be
helpful as well now the question about
taming your desires in general as a
young person
so you know you're going to see some
philosophers basically write young
people off like aristotle for example
he's you know if you've ever read the
nick of mccain ethics at the very
beginning of the work he says something
that my students you know
get riled up about every time you can't
teach young people ethics you know until
maybe they're 30 years old why not
because they're too driven by their
passions and desires
and
this is a silly statement by aristotle
the one thing that is not silly about it
is his pointing out that some people are
immature in years and other people are
immature in their development so there's
some 50 year olds who don't have their
proverbial [ __ ] together and you can't
effectively teach them ethics either
i think it's actually good
as young people
to develop that that domain
that uh
goldman called emotional intelligence
you know being able to recognize when
you're feeling a particular emotion and
this extends not just to the emotions
proper but to moods to desires and
aversions
drives and things like that and i think
there's a lot of philosophical
literature and psychotherapeutic
literature that can help with that
and being able to recognize what's going
on with other people and then developing
some regulation and it doesn't have to
be a hundred percent but
you know learning how to if you're like
getting angry about something or you're
getting like really attracted to
somebody and you're like oh but there
are there's some red flags with them
learning how to be able to like not
necessarily like just cut your emotions
off but to guide them right that that
can be
quite helpful too
and
um
[Music]
that would fit in with the taming
desires part right
so there's an entire literature out
there of understanding the emotions
going back to ancient times that i think
is quite useful and i would i would
suggest sort of eclectically drawing
on it and studying different um
different you know
frameworks and then seeing what what's
valuable
in them
um
rafael says just want to say
uh love your videos i'm from brazil
study philosophy by myself i read the
books then come here to see your
lectures so i can better understand them
yeah that's i'm glad to hear that or to
read that because um that is that's one
of the things that i came to realize
when i first started posting my class
videos over a decade ago there were
comments from people who are they were
they were saying a couple things one was
i'm a student my professor won't
actually explain anything thank you for
posting this because now i actually
understand what plato's saying or cicero
or whoever right
and then there were a lot of people who
were like i'm
i can't go to university i don't have
the money or i don't live in a place
that has it or you know my country is
kind of in a mess or i'm i'm you know
working too much i've got
responsibilities
so
being able to
you know
listen in on your classes
and read the text when i can get access
to them
very helpful for me lots of people were
saying that and so i came to realize
that there was this
vast number of what we call lifelong
learners out there
and that the you know whatever i created
could be useful for them not that i have
like the final word on on a lot of stuff
you know i mean
there's for any given thinker that i
work on there's probably
you know many people who are who are
better scholars on that person than i am
but you know i'm the one who put it out
there sort of like the half hour hegel
series you know wouldn't you rather have
uh somebody who's like a hegel scholar
doing that you know straight that's all
they do
yeah probably but
they're not willing to get up there and
get in front of the chalkboard and do it
and i am so
so i'm glad that the stuff is helpful
for you um that's really good
well here's a good one about hegel ahmad
what's your take on ip elites genesis
and structure of the phenomenology
spirit classic secondary text um
hippolyte if you don't know john ipolit
was also the french translator of
hegel's phenomenology of spirit and he
managed to take a single volume work
and his translation is two volumes he
says how the hell did that happen it's
got all these lovely footnotes uh
throughout the entire thing so it's sort
of like him
translating and in a dialogue with hegel
and the reader which i just love you
know i think that's amazing i don't
actually have a copy of that i have
photocopies because
my
mentor when i was in graduate school he
had that on the shelf and then he had
his own annotations
in the side and i was like would you
mind if i uh photocopied these
um
and he's like yeah refined go ahead
that's the way he talked and so i i went
and photocopied every friggin page
of that and i've got it stored away
somewhere so i actually should buy some
uh copies and i think that hippolytes
you know his translation has been
superseded in french just as like
bayley's has and miller's has recently
um
but i think it's it's you know it's good
and i think his his commentary is is
quite useful
um
does he cover everything
in as great a depth as i might like
no there's places where he um
doesn't say as much as as i would prefer
but
you know what are you gonna do i mean
when you write your own stuff you come
to realize how much work it is
all right so here's one from roughly
bumble good to see you here too as well
any thoughts on gilgamesh
or on how certain major old testament
events also take place in its narrative
yeah i mean i think gilgamesh is a great
uh work of literature that everybody
should read you know there's there's a
lot of this mesopotamian stuff that's
really cool like you know the anumilish
everyone should read that too or
you know the enkei stories um it's all
really wonderful things and when i teach
world religions i actually i don't have
them read gilgamesh
although you know i could actually that
might be a good idea but i do have them
read um the anumalish and we talk about
the you know the model of the conflict
between the gods gilgamesh is also you
know broaching as as is some other
ancient literature some really really
important themes
why do we have to die
you know what's what's the underworld
like
what is the purpose of living
[Music]
what kind of good is friendship
so it's really worth checking out and
it's got this cool hero gilgamesh right
and then his buddy and kedu
the hairy guy um and you know
are there are there
connections with
old testament narratives i mean we can
call them events if we want we don't
know if they actually really happened or
not um
[Music]
i mean literature reflects literature
it's these things don't develop in a
complete vacuum
and you know um
what we nowadays think of as as judaism
developed over millennia within a um
complex middle eastern context so
um it would be surprising if like there
weren't any interconnections i mean
another another uh religion that also
exerted massive influence on judaism and
then christianity and even on islam is
zoroastrianism
and you know the the reasons for that
are kind of complex and geopolitical
right
um so that's
quite interesting
all right let's see what else we got um
[Music]
leslie says the top psych hospital's
president admitted he had sex with
multiple patients oh that's horrible
studies show around 10 percent of
psychoanalysts have sex with patients my
psychoanalyst affirmed having sex with
patients should i report a psychoanalyst
who affirmed this
if i knew my report would be believed
and should i stop seeing the therapist
yes to both i mean
those are major red flags it's it's an
abuse of power in a uneven power dynamic
and it also violates uh
you know the code of ethics that you
know there's various codes of ethics out
there i know the one for the american
psycho psychological association uh
pretty well and it says you can't do
that i mean you can't even have like
business relationships outside of things
with clients
clients are supposed to be clients and
that's it you're not supposed to as we
say have dual roles right
and if you do you better have somebody
else supervising that and i don't think
when it comes to sex with patients that
you're going to get one of your peers
signing off on it and saying yeah yeah
go for it that sounds great
same thing goes by the way for
university professors you know people
always have like but what if you fall in
love with them too bad
find somebody else you know the people
who prey on those who are
in
one down power positions there's always
something skeevy going on
and this is very important too for um uh
you know
a psychiatrist or psychologist or
counselor
they're supposed to have some good
judgment
and so the fact that they would
screw a patient or client or whatever
means that
they shouldn't be
in the therapeutic situation at all
probably so i yeah i'd report them
you're doing a good thing if you do
report them
and if it turns out to be false well you
know they can they can sort that out in
the the committee stuff you know
all right uh
nl other voices if you had to pick one
thousand plateaus anti-oedipus kafka or
what is philosophy i've heard you're
more averse of deluse plus qatari over
to lose solo have you spent much time
with any of those books yeah i mean i
started reading to lose
ann
gatari over two and a half decades ago
anti-oedipus was the first book that i
read back in it would have been like
1993
and um
i've you know i i i'm not a verse that's
the wrong word i just think that the
lose doesn't do as good work with qatari
as he does on his own i think toulouse
is better i mean if you had to ask me
what are my favorites
essays critical and clinical and logic
of sense
that's it you know
i mean i like his history books her
history of philosophy books you know his
book on nietzsche
you know
that's quite good
you know a lot of what he's doing in
logic of sense is history of philosophy
as well
um
and uh
the leibniz book you know the fold i
really enjoy that
um
but you know and it's not as if i'm like
oh anti-oedipus stay away no it's just i
i don't think that it's as
i don't think it's as
thoughtful and and rigorous as his other
stuff um i think that he really really
enjoyed what qatari brought to the table
but that doesn't mean that i think that
it's uh good stuff so you know
all right um
abradon hello thoughts on locks theory
of self-ownership ownership in the stoic
oikios proprioception two totally
different things the stoics don't say
you own yourself
with lock it's it's def it's got an
interesting way of being used in his
time it's definitely been
misappropriated by libertarians all the
way up to the present
and you know and you notice that people
like nozick have to propose alternate
ways of making sense out of mixing your
labor and property to to make sense of
things i think it's a it's sort of a
non-starter when i hear somebody talking
about it i just kind of zone out because
i'm like yeah this person isn't really
worth
paying that much attention to just like
when you know nowadays people are like
well the woke this and the work that i'm
like well
that's definitely somebody who's not
worth paying attention to
you know other than
how they could mess things up
so i'm i'm not a fan of locke's theory
of self-ownership the stoic theory of
oikios is not so much connected with
proprioception it's rather connected
with um self-affection and
self-perception right proprioception is
like you know moving around and stuff
like that right
um we get this mainly coming from
hereocles and a little bit from cicero
and then from some other discussions
i think people make too much of it
um
it's not supposed to be
you know like a doctrine in and of
itself it's supposed to connect up with
other stoic doctrines
so yeah
all right uh cinder how do you get over
the feeling that you're not doing things
on time i'm 21 i always have this
nagging feeling i'm behind oh that's a
good question so
um it depends on what the thing is like
if i
say that i'm going to get something done
at a certain date
and then it happens later
then i'm behind and i'm actually looking
at a book that came out
much later
than expected this is you know stoicism
today uh selected uh essays volume three
that leia goldrick and i edited and and
i you know i got a lot of stuff
uh and
so a lot of projects going on and and i
was mostly the drag on this this this
came out last
uh december uh and it probably should
have come out like a year before that
right
so i was behind on that and that's
objectively so because i made that
commitment
if it comes to things like oh all of my
friends are
you know getting this happens a lot in
people's 20s all my friends are finding
relationships and getting married and
buying a house and having kids what's
going on with me
well who says that they're doing the
right thing i mean a lot of the
decisions we make in our 20s about our
romantic partners and jobs and stuff
like that turn out to be you know poorly
informed and
you know divorce rate's about 50 right
so
uh
and breakups are probably even more for
relationships so you know a lot of times
we're not really behind we're just kind
of you know we're not doing exactly what
everybody else does
um you know when it comes to like
project writing things
some people don't start their writing
career
until their 60s and then they start
putting out good stuff other people
start early
um it all depends along along the way i
mean there's some things where like
you know
if you if you're going to do certain
physical things you probably do need to
want to get them in
early on like
it's too late for me to be a runner
because i've already torn two ligaments
in one of my knees and you know
that's just not in the cards for me um
but that's probably not the case for you
right you're probably thinking about
other other kinds of things and you're
you're not really behind um are there
any philosophers who talk about like
feeling like you're behind nobody comes
to mind offhand but you could
you could think about like um theories
of human development and and poke around
in them and also look at you know some
of these philosophers and
take a look at the works that they put
out when they got older
and accumulated some wisdom you know so
all right um
ab
delhi
do you believe in god yep
uh online person
any suggestions for texts that look at
role metaphor plays and thinking and
interpreting at the role metaphor plays
in thinking and interpreting experience
um
yeah i mean this is uh
there's like tons and tons of stuff out
there um this is kind of a commonplace
in the entire like
you know philosophy of language and
semiotics uh tradition
um
i mean i think that's somebody who's
really good for getting into that stuff
is umberto echo
because he's also great at being a
gateway into looking at other people as
well
um i would be
careful
when people say that like this is the
metaphor and this is how metaphors work
metaphors are pretty complicated there's
a lot of different kinds of metaphors
so i'd be careful about people who are
making two sweeping claims you know
another person who comes to mind too uh
paul recur he's actually got a book
called the rule of metaphor that that
would be good to check out so
um
ricky says what are your thoughts on
alan bloom thanks for your lectures on
the apology and credo helped get through
political philosophy glad the lectures
were helpful i'm not a fan of alan bloom
i think he was kind of an old you know
sour puss in many respects
um his closing of the american mind was
pretty cringy even when it first came
out because i i i remember when it came
out
and uh there were parts of it where you
were like wow this guy's pretty out of
touch you know
um
that's that's basically it you know i
mean
he's known for being a commentator on
plato and
lots of commentators on plato i don't
know that he's particularly important
um
so he i i'll put it to you this way he's
not anybody i ever think about unless
people ask me about him
zeno says i have officially finished
being in time that's wonderful now you
can restart reading it because you're
never finished with great philosophical
works
you have made it to the end and now you
know you've gotten through your first
reading of it now you can like decide
what parts you want to go back to you
know
what things you think are really
important and what's going to stick with
you
uh alfonso what are my thoughts on
quantum physics
quantum physics exists
there's a lot of people who
use
quantum as an adjective to try to like
make things seem sexier
usually no real connection with quantum
physics i'm not really sure what you're
asking me
about
uh object abdullah jabar why is martin
heidegger so hard to understand he's a
difficult thinker most difficult
thinkers are hard to understand just
keep at it keep working at it
and eventually you will understand them
you know
all right
um
[Music]
jb has a funny observation here
definitely not uploading myself to the
cloud while amazon and google are
running it so this is actually
there's like the short term yes you're
completely right about that or microsoft
or
apple or
who am i leaving out apple amazon google
microsoft
who's the other the big five could have
been yahoo but yahoo you know crap the
bed
when they had the opportunity
facebook facebook meta right they're
trying to break into that sort of thing
yeah i mean who the hell would would
think oh yeah i'm sure that they're
gonna be good to me once i make myself
totally vulnerable to these massive
corporations because they give a crap
about me so much now i'm sure they're
going to treat me even better when
they're responsible for me
in perpetuity right no of course not
and you could you could say well i'll
work with a private company you know
how do you know 20 years from now
they're not going to get bought out by
some other company that does something
different you know the notion of duty
pretty shaky among
corporations these days isn't it except
when they're pretty small and close to
the ground close to their consumer base
so i don't you know
i i wouldn't uh
i'd be very leery about that right
um toothless tiger shark does the loeb
classical library carry aries didymus i
couldn't find it if you couldn't find it
then they don't carry it
so
it's pretty easy to see their their
entire library no there's there's
actually a uh
a different translation of aries dynamis
that has the greek on one side and the
english on the other side just google it
it'll it'll come up on
amazon
i forget exactly who the publisher is
it's got
i will say this too
sometimes you look at the translators
choices in that translation and you're
like
this is a little
weird why did you translate this greek
term this way
you know it's almost as if they needed
to like make it their own
uh and i it's always unfortunate um
but it for the most part it's not going
to lead you astray so
alex uh do you have any familiarity with
islamic philosophy avid senator robbie
alvarez yeah i have familiarity but i
don't have enough to
consider my myself enough of an expert
to do videos on it the next question
that people why why don't you do islamic
philosophy well because
hell i don't have to do everything
there's plenty of other people out there
who could be shooting videos on that and
they're better suited to it you know
marquette university just down the road
he has the aquinas and the arabs project
and graduate students are actually
studying arabic so they can they can
read these texts um
and uh not all of us have to do do
everything
i
you know i like to
observe my limitations um
so
all right trek taught us is it worth it
to read complete works of some
philosophers or should we just better
read the key works of more philosophers
totally depends there isn't a one size
you should do this sort of thing i mean
if you
want to so let's take heidegger as an
example right
we're fortunate in that
not only do we have a lot of you know
his his main works translated like being
in time for example
um
but we also have all these lectures now
that have been translated in in recent
decades
and you know if you want to understand
heidegger do you need to read everything
no i mean i understand heidegger and i
haven't read every single thing when i
when i find something that i want i'm
really interested in like uh you know
his lectures on aristotle or his
lectures on the phenomenology of
religious life i buy it and i'm like
holy [ __ ] let's check this out you know
but it's not as if i didn't understand
heidegger before that right
and it depends on what you want to do
with with your studies i mean there are
some philosophers who
you could read your way through fairly
easily like you know think about rene
descartes
the adam and tannery i think is three or
four volumes um and it includes all of
his major works and his letters and and
stuff like that um but you know do you
need to read all that if you have a
fascination with descartes maybe
or you want to be a descartes scholar
harry harry frogford actually in one of
his books admitted that the reason why
he chose to become a descartes scholar
was because the canon of works was so
small he thought it was more manageable
than like you know reading aristotle or
hegel or somebody like that
so it's it's totally up to you what you
want to do with that
um
rt whitby thomas aquinas said that to be
created the image of god is to have
intelligence
um rationality actually so if we find
intelligent aliens does that mean that
they would also be created in the image
of god
insofar as as you think that that's what
the image of god is then the answer
would be yes right
um what are the other ways in which the
image of god is understood rene
descartes says that we are made in the
image of god in the sense that we have
an infinite will
maybe aliens have that
um the great uh christian
uh uh you know early
patristic author clement of alexandria
so that we are created in the image of
god and that we are musical
isn't that an interesting idea this is
in the stromada by the way
um
so we would see whether there's
something like the equivalent of music
think close encounters of the third kind
right
it's not as if there's a single take
about what it is to be created in the
image and likeness of god right the icon
or um
like what is the uh
in the book of wisdom there's a
different word that's used in the greek
uh anyway it does doesn't really matter
in the septuagint um
this is an interesting thing though and
and
even if you're a secular person
um
somebody who i did work on recently and
i'm actually going to be
putting out a medium piece about is ola
stapleton
and when he's talking about aliens
do you know what he calls them when
they've reached a certain level of
development
other men
other human beings and he talks about
the terrestrial human beings that's us
and then he talks about the
other human beings
throughout the galaxy some of whom don't
even they're not even connected to us
uh by like arising in the same way that
we do some of them are plant men some of
them are
other uh
uh derived things you know um
so you know yeah if if alien
life
reaches a sort of a certain level of
whatever we want to call being human
then you know they're human
um
i guess we would say so
all right
um
extinctionist records black metal why
aren't you vegan
because i don't want to be vegan and and
most vegans that i've met are kind of
[ __ ]
um you know um i i don't i don't i'm not
you know convinced that i absolutely
have to be vegan it's interesting that
people always like
frame it in that way right like the
burden of proof is on you you know i
mean i think we can say let's eliminate
a lot of animal cruelty and
um you know if you're gonna have meat
have it ethically
farmed and slaughtered you know we're
mostly pescatarian now and we buy
our uh fish
from uh you know sitka salmon and places
like that where it's a sustainable
practices and
[Music]
you know it's fair labor practices and
stuff like that
[Music]
so you know i'm not i'm not that
concerned about about becoming a vegan i
think that we should focus on sort of
incremental change rather than this like
you're on this side or this side kind of
stuff you know
uh brian collins i've been trying to get
into dostoevsky at this point he might
not be for me is there a barrier to
getting into dostoyevsky most people
don't bring up i like kafka and henry
james a lot
yeah i mean
i
i kind of think that a lot of people go
wrong by
saying i'm going to read dostoyevsky
what do i need to read oh crime and
punishment or brothers karamazov
brothers karmazov is a slog you know
it's not my favorite novel by far
i only teach parts of it i mean i
wouldn't who's got the time to teach the
whole freaking thing right uh if i was
going to teach it in a class
um
you know his his novels vary
considerably from novel to novel i will
say one thing that is kind of
off-putting about about dostoevsky and
it's russian literature in general
you almost need like a card to keep
track of who the hell is who you know
but this is a problem not just for
dostoevsky but also for gogol and janjav
and pushkin and all these other people
um
i you know my favorite dostoevsky works
are
the possessed and uh notes from
underground and i
i'm not that big on part two of notes
from underground quite frankly you know
i'm mostly interested in the first part
so
um
i don't get into henry james myself um i
found him kind of kind of tough for me
but i think other people really like him
all right uh evan hope you're well just
wanted to thank you for the great videos
and content self-directed studies of
hagel and descartes have helped me
through some tough periods and books
alike oh that's very good i'm glad glad
that the the videos could be helpful for
you i think a lot of times it's what you
do with them rather than the videos
themselves
uh your average french canadian
immigrant been reading a lot of cogsi
and game theory and it's concerning how
much we're influenced and determined and
how much we're bodily how can we
possibly have soul free will
i mean maybe the cog cyan game theory is
making sweeping assumptions as part of
their methodology
that you shouldn't automatically buy
into and believe
there's just a suggestion you know
um
i mean do you have a choice about
whether you you have a viewpoint on free
will or not
you got free will
i mean
do we have free will in the sense like
we can choose anything we want no and
that's usually what they're attacking
right
um but why would you believe the kagsai
people half of what they say is like
these tiny little brain studies done on
a few people and they draw these big
sweeping conclusions it's just like
psychology people in general you know
and games theory holy [ __ ] is that full
of assumptions
you got to read like the classic
literature on this stuff you know like
games and decisions by lucha raffia and
you're like this is all mathematics with
a little bit of economics thrown in and
wow are these
subjects who have no you know background
or they're like pure
imaginary subjects so i mean if you
remind yourself of that you might um
develop a kind of critical distance
towards
those things
uh message who are the best authors who
talk about how god influences the world
through divine providence problem of
evil mind body problem
i mean i don't know that that you're
asking an awful lot right there so if
you only asked one of those maybe i
could say who i think the best authors
are
but you know how god influences the
world the problem of evil and the mind
body problem
i don't know
uh logic what do you think about meta
ethics and what's your position on i
think med ethics is [ __ ] and um
because it's turned itself in to a field
that's like we're doing meta ethics not
not you know substantive ethics or pick
whatever else you want to call it
every single tradition in normative
ethics take utilitarianism for example
has meta-ethical discussions actually
read the bentham read the mill not just
ethics textbooks or articles but read
the actual literature emanuel kant right
is you know by by when he's talking
about the hetero heteron heteronomi of
the will that's what we call meta ethics
so the distinction between normative
ethics and meta ethics is kind of
[ __ ] and arbitrary
and i think kind of self-serving for the
people who claim that they're doing meta
ethics
every substantive ethics contains a meta
ethics every meta-ethical position
winds up turning into a substantive
ethics
so
you can use the term if you want but i
think it's kind of slippery it's sort of
like language and meta language you've
always got meta language right it's it's
more of a
pragmatic distinction than a real
distinction and certainly should not be
a disciplinary distinction
uh thera decay do you think an anarchist
society with no power dynamics is
feasible
i don't even think it's conceivable
frankly once you start thinking things
through
let alone feasible feasibility would
require we have to have a way of getting
from here to there and i don't see how
that's going to happen
alexander graybar any idea where i can
find writings on rub heraclitus google
it i mean
yeah you can find heraclitus's fragments
right online you know you can even find
it in the ancient greek just google it
and and it's super easy to get there's
plenty of other books you could buy too
usually they'll be like fragments of the
pre-socratics or you know
philosophy before socrates or something
like that and they'll all have the same
basic
stuff right so super easy to we we don't
have heraclitus's original writings we
just have
fragments and everybody's got the same
stuff
why sophistry i just graduated i wanted
to say i appreciated all your content
during my time in school you distilled
topics into a form that made it so much
easier to understand thank you glad and
i hope that you continue
finding the stuff useful because i hope
you continue studying this stuff maybe
you take a little break you know it's
fine to do that i actually took a break
between undergraduate and grad school
where i was you know less studying
philosophy more reading literature and
working on languages and
exercising and working two jobs and you
know saving up money and stuff like that
but you know hopefully you want to
keep on um
you know
keep on studying the stuff so
all right uh zeno advice for reading
capitalism and schizophrenia i have it
on my shelf never touched
i mean i don't have any like
straightforward advice get it down start
reading it you know make make maybe make
yourself a nice
cup of coffee or tea or whatever you
like have some snacks and whatever it
takes to get you to do it right or maybe
you could join a reading group where
there's accountability and you have to
do it those would be my suggestions
uh christian fernandez
good books for beginners in philosophy a
good place to start studying philosophy
of architecture i wouldn't have a clue
i'm not an architect you know
uh it's not an area of my my work
um
good books for beginners in philosophy
uh if you google you know sadler 10 10
uh
books philosophy i've got an article on
that you know
in medium
that's probably my most read thing
they're not the only works that you can
start with but i i give reasons why each
of them would be a good thing to start
with
um kayla can you break down midgley's
first argument is as follows if moral
isolationism collect is correct then one
can respect a culture without judging it
i don't know i'd have to get uh
midgley's piece
about moral isolationism out there and
read it i don't have it at like in the
top of my head so i don't know
um
all right
jolene says have you engaged with the
work of charles sanders purse
yeah i think for the first time probably
25 years ago maybe less or maybe more
um
would you recommend any specific text to
get into him primary secondary well
always primary i mean if you want to
read if you want to read a thinker read
the thinker
don't read something about him seeing as
he only wrote papers he is hard to get
into
well i mean
i don't see why only writing papers
would make somebody hard to get into as
opposed to writing books
purse is kind of tricky and that he's
got his own vocabulary so
you know
i would uh get like the selected
writings
book that is readily available you can
find a lot of libraries and bookstores
and
just start working your way through it
and um
[Music]
realize that he's got kind of a
convoluted writing style
and uh you know he's no william james so
to speak right but thank god he's also
not a john dewey if you want to talk
about
overly complicated prose uh john dewey
is
really somebody uh who who did that um
you just got to keep plowing at him and
and you know you'll you'll get it
um
[Music]
nick if you could have one philosophy
get the hollywood biopic treatment so
one philosophical movement i think you
mean
who would you choose and who would you
like to direct i like the idea of darren
aronofsky directing the trial of
socrates i mean i i don't know i i don't
pay attention to directors all that much
uh i'm not a film person
um
so you're talking about like a a
particular instance right um there there
are actually i think things out there
with the trial of socrates
on youtube um
[Music]
so a philosophical event you mean
um
i don't know i'd have to think about
that
uh it's not something i i often give a
lot of thought to you know
um
what we should turn into
film or movie stuff i think in part
because
most of the people who do film or movie
stuff that's connected with philosophy
just like they do with mathematics
they do such a terrible job with it even
shows like the the good place i think do
do a a mediocre job
with things
it's uh
it's hard to make this kind of stuff
like into hollywood compelling
you know
it's not hard to make good
philosophically deep um film but you
gotta introduce
you know
the willingness to not explain
everything and to not like constantly
guide your viewers along you know in
order to do that and i think europeans
tend to be better at that than than
americans so
all right um
etheric a day can communism work
depends on what you mean by communism
that depends on what you mean by work
you know
um
alfonso uh goes back to the quantum
thing thank you for answering that i was
referring to quantum teleportation
i don't know anything about that i i
don't know enough about that to have an
opinion so
um
all right ibn where would you say
suggest is the best place of starting to
read philosophy well i i gave a response
to that a little bit earlier about the
10 books you could start with
but as you say you find nietzsche
interesting start with nietzsche
first philosophy book i ever read was
camus
myth of sisyphus i understood maybe a
tenth of it at the time when i was
14 or 15.
um i did read nietzsche you know when i
was a teenager
and uh didn't understand most of what i
was reading there either but didn't
break my brain by doing that
uh
abdullah barr asks me to do something
i've already done can you make videos on
michelle foucault
you gotta google
jesus people ask me about stuff
as if we we don't have a search function
in youtube itself i mean
you just go to my channel and type in
the stuff you're looking for and if it's
there it'll pop up and if and if it's
not there it's because i haven't done
stuff on it you know
uh is there
jack heaton is there anything in the
fourth political theory allah dugan and
millerman i don't know because i haven't
read dugan so
i suspect it's probably kind of warmed
over traditionalist [ __ ] from the
previous
uh century or two two centuries but i
don't really know you know so i'd have
to i'd have to read it
um
let's see here
aidan i get the impression you're
catholic have you looked into eastern
orthodoxy
buddy i used to teach religious studies
classes and i've been engaged in
ecumenical dialogue for decades and
decades so yeah i know i know a bit
about eastern orthodoxy uh what do you
think about the emphasis on mystical
theology as opposed to a more scholastic
based one i think that anybody who
articulates things in that way doesn't
know anything about theology
there's lots of mystical theology in the
catholic tradition there's lots of
scholasticism
if you go back far enough in the
orthodox
these these sorts of like this versus
this
big picture stuff
those are non-starters
um
greg if you don't want to be an employee
and work for someone else is there a
contradiction in becoming yourself an
employer why would there be a
contradiction i i don't see that it's a
you know
uh
you you're always going to work for
somebody else depending on how you
define employee employees a relative
term by the way you know employee to
employer or client you know to patron or
whatever
um sansa here's a good question did your
philosophical pursuit ever have you may
have less or more faith in god
um depends on what you mean by faith for
me faith is something that is not like
just a bunch of propositions that you
assent to or something like that faith
is something you live
right it's dynamic
um
faith without works is dead
and uh so
you know people like to talk a lot about
faith but i think we got to be really
careful in that and yeah i mean
i i you know came into graduate school
having left the
church a long time before
and i came back to it and got confirmed
by
a guy now who's who's a cardinal believe
it or not uh he was a bishop at the time
and uh i did so because of reading and
studying people like anselm of
canterbury
and it wasn't just like the ontological
argument no it was his works and seeing
his life and then engaging with
people who who
practiced what they preached you know
nobody ever converts because of just one
thing william james is totally right
about this in
varieties of religious experience i
think
uh
all right let's see we'll we'll take
some other people's uh
uh
things here
so trilotto de taco has a retort i'm not
sure what maybe you're just bad at math
yeah i could be bad at math i mean i did
major in it as an undergraduate i did do
work in the foundations of mathematics
but yeah you're probably right i'm just
bad at math
um
all right uh
elijah any recommended read after
finishing chefs off all things are
possible yeah so
there's um
[Music]
all things are possible are often
bundled together with um penultimate
words and that's definitely worth
reading he's also got some early works
that are really really good talking
about
like
dostoevsky at nietzsche
all these are available too online you
can you can find these for free
um athens in jerusalem one of his latest
works
you know more mature works um that's a
classic
um
in in the 30s he discovers kierkegaard
and he's like holy crap how did i not
know about this guy and then in his book
on kierkegaard
he says kierkegaard didn't go far enough
that's that's worth checking out as well
um
eben says how do you start reading plato
i got a whole video on that a
self-directed study
on plato you might check that out
um
abaddijar are most modern philosophers
from germany they're not i mean i don't
know where you would possibly get that
idea from but that's definitely not not
true
uh killabus what does it say on your
shirt so
i
here we go
got my wasp uh
concert shirt we're gonna be seeing
wasp and armored saint later on this
year
um here in milwaukee i've never seen
either of them but i've been listening
to them boy since i was a teenager you
know i'm a metal head from from the
growing up in the 70s and the 80s so i'm
really looking forward to seeing wasp
although of course it's not seeing the
classic wasp it's blackie lawless and
whoever he's got hired and he's not
playing bass anymore he's playing guitar
um
chris holmes randy piper you know not
with him at this time they have their
own things by the way uh randy piper has
has his own band and so does chris
holmes
um
sire what did nietzsche exactly mean
with the economy of the great style
combining enthusiasm with power
i don't know i mean i'd have to like
find the textual reference and take a
look at it so i don't know
column was any thoughts about so sir
yeah uh ferdinand de socier is well
worth reading he sort of gets things
started when it comes to
semiology
[Music]
you know essentially french
semiotics you know is very he's very
important in
structural linguistics
so you know jakobson and helmslev and
all those other people are building off
of dissoci
um
i would read his quarter linguistic
genral i remember the translation of it
that because i we were reading it a
buddy of mine and i remember i i had the
french version and he had the english
version and he'd like say stuff to me
and i'd be like well that's not what the
french says at all so i think you got to
be careful about
some of the translations of the core
one thing that that dissociates says
early on in that work that i thought was
really on point
you cannot be a linguist without
studying and understanding multiple
languages
it sort it would be sort of like being a
musicologist and only listening to heavy
metal you know you know that area but
you don't know anything else right
so if you want to be good in a subject
area and theorize about it you really
got to learn the stuff in that that
subject area right so if you want to
like be a philosopher you know
philosopher of history you got to read a
lot of history right um if you want to
be a philosopher of art you better like
spend some time probably doing some some
artistic production as well as
appreciation you know so
all right uh
brian collins have you ever taught dh
lawrence i have not you know um
[Music]
you say i've been getting into him a bit
especially studies in classic american
literature he does come off as a weirdo
he is a weirdo
but so are most of the people we read
how controversial is he in lit
philosophical circles he's not
controversial at all in philosophical
circles because nobody reads them you
know
um
or you know very few people do
literature i don't know i'm not a
literature person i don't i would
suspect that they consider him kind of
old hat these days
and that he's not all that controversial
at all
british floof the best intro
introductory philosophers heidegger
uh
you know
i guess if you're going to do that you'd
start off on you know what is
metaphysics but heidegger is definitely
not introductory level stuff
um
zeno i have hard time agreeing with all
the great philosophers and have trouble
forming my own opinion any advice you
don't have to agree with all the the
ancient philosophers or great
philosophers
if you did you would be
logically incoherent and probably unable
to function because they don't all
believe the same thing right i would
worry less about whether you agree or
not and worry more about understanding
their their viewpoints and if you take
that off your shoulders you'll probably
at least at this time be a lot happier
and you don't have to form your own
opinion who says that you have to have
your own point of view um it's enough to
like understand
somebody else's point of view and say
yeah this this makes sense
um
originality is really overrated you know
uh kartoffelmanden what do you think
about people like lukach who engages
with hegel from a marxist perspective
more power to him you know
people can engage with hegel from
whatever perspective they want to
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
going to be on point
um that they're not going to like put on
some some you know blinders
but uh everybody's got blinders you know
it's not as if you ever approach hagel
from a pure hegelian perspective
because we know that hegelianism breaks
up into different different camps which
includes marxism right so at least
that's not quite as far away than like
say engaging it from a russellian
perspective rejecting the british
idealist hegelian philosophers of his
own time right so i i don't have a
problem with it
uh ariane where would you move on to
after introduction of philosophy like of
russell bertrand if you're a
self-learner well
[Music]
tell yourself half of what i've read in
russell's history is probably [ __ ]
and off base i would read primary texts
i always say go back and read primary
texts if you want somebody who's a
contemporary of russell who's actually a
decent historian of philosophy actually
more than a decent one a good careful
one friedrich cobblestone he's got a
whole history of philosophy you could
you could read and then you'll get you
know russell's uh
nagging voice out of your head i guess
uh chris have you read agamben i have
indeed uh colomous what do you think of
roderick chisholm's engagement with
anselm and his peace on free will
haven't read it but i i'm willing to bet
that chisholm doesn't know much about
anselm
um
because it doesn't you know that doesn't
strike me as something that you know
when i think anselm scholarship i don't
think about uh chisholm you know
um
[Music]
abdullah jabar is getting a little
contentious here why are most
philosophers men don't tell me i'm wrong
historically most philosophers have been
men in the present it sure as hell isn't
the case
i mean
these sweeping assumptions you know i
mean why why have most writers been men
i mean read virginia woolf's a room of
one's own and she'll tell you all about
this this phenomenon or read mary
wollstonecraft's vindication of the
rights of women women kind of get
screwed a lot of the time through most
of history
we know this to be the case even
big-name philosophers
like for example russell or i mean a.g
grayling has a history of philosophy
that he's put out recently
almost no engagement with the women
philosophers who were there like
margaret cavendish or mary
wollstonecraft you know he mentions
hannah rent very briefly simone bouvoir
very briefly
and a few others but he totally ignores
the rest including princess elizabeth of
bohemia or
hildegard of bingham or you know all
these other these other greats but you
know if you're talking about the late
20th century in the early 21st century
it's pretty
you know especially in like history of
philosophy
it's pretty even
i mean
i could name you just an aristotle and
stoicism scholarship like hundreds
of major female scholars who's not i
don't cite every single one of them
but i do say quite a few and i've been
fortunate to meet some of them like
julia anna's rock star of philosophy or
um i haven't met martha nussbaum but
she'd be in that case gizella striker
nancy sherman i mean there's lots of
women philosophers i've worked under
how many shares
about half of the chairs that i've
worked under have been women so
you know that's just not the case um
alex do you think hegel is the
protestant aquinas no i i think these
so and so being this this sort of thing
those are usually misleading um
hegel is is doing a different kind of
project and his protestantism like um
uh
what was his um
blanking on his name i can i could see
his hegel commentary uh
in in front of my face
um stanley rosen stanley rosen observed
that if hegel was an orthodox protestant
he was in a church of one meaning that
he was the only person who believed what
what he believed right so no he's he's
definitely
if he's a protestant he's a really
unusual
protestant right it's better to see
hegel as like doing his his own
humanistic thing over on the side
um nitrous what's your opinion on
islamic theology do you see any
correlation between it in classical
modern western philosophy
i don't have opinions on islamic
theology because i'm not an expert in
that
so
are there correlations between it in
classical modern western philosophy
depends on what you mean by classical
there's certainly like similar themes
explored because sometimes they're
working off of the same texts you know
and thinkers like aristotle right
so obviously they're going to be
connections
chris what are your opinions on agabem i
think he's probably the best living
philosopher well on that we're
definitely gonna disagree i mean i think
his work is interesting i think he
really has gone off the deep end when
when it came to covid so
um
trollo
or trollolo uh have you read nassim
telev and if so what's your opinion i've
read enough of his stuff to be like yeah
overrated
um and he really has a circle of fanboys
around him doesn't he especially on
twitter i've seen him going after people
and his fanboys going after people
um
i think he's way overrated um
uh columbus anne conway is another woman
philosopher yeah there's like tons of
them out there you know
uh aryan i went to cobblestone's review
and it said to learn russell
when i went to russell it said to learn
to rant
i also saw people suggesting anthony
kenny here and there you're going the
wrong places
just read cobblestone i mean why are you
[ __ ] around with reviews of stuff
rather than actually just like diving in
you know
um
durant the the story of philosophy okay
that's that's fun um you're getting more
durant than you are the people that that
you're checking out same thing with
russell uh same thing with toulouse by
the way you know at least with duluth
it's interesting or heidegger right
um cobblestone is a much more careful
scholar that's that's all you got to do
um james ferry is late to the game about
duluth and gatari have you ever thought
about doing something on capitalism and
schizophrenia
if somebody wants to commission my time
to take away from all the other things
that i'm doing because they're so
interested in me doing work on a
particular person
more power to them but they're gonna
have to you know come up with the the
money for doing that
um i've done stuff on toulouse
um i'll probably do more stuff on duluz
i considered to lose his work on his own
much more
interesting and and rigorous than the
stuff that he does with qatari but if
people really want me to to do that you
know uh okay
um
aberdeen laura hill's attempted to argue
that loch derived most self-ownership
idea from the stoics i mean anybody can
argue anything they want to who gives a
[ __ ] i don't know who who lisa hill is
you know
there's like literally
tens of thousands of of like secondary
lit people out there doing stuff in the
history of philosophy
i don't think lot got it from the stoics
i mean that seems very implausible to me
i considered it quite odd as the stocks
talk about our bodies as being rented to
us at best
yeah okay yeah maybe
and different views on suicide yeah i
mean people will make any sort of
argument they can to try to get their
stuff published in some journal but it
doesn't mean that it's that it's true
you know
um
alexander if you could have dinner with
any philosopher past or present who
would it be and why i don't know i mean
there's a whole bunch of them who i'd
probably enjoy having dinner with i was
just actually working on some stuff in
antisthenes
and in diogenes liertes he's mentioned
is like being this really great
conversationalist so that that might be
fun kant apparently was a great
conversationalist at dinner parties too
you know
um
and um
you know i probably would like hanging
out with descartes he seems like a cool
guy
and some uh introduced something
uh you know the benedictines it's
supposed to be somebody reading
and then everybody's eating and they
shut the hell up and just listen to the
reading
he introduced an innovation of having
like discussions
so he probably would be kind of fun i
don't know there's there's all sorts of
people you know i don't have a
any one philosopher who i'd be into uh
british floof have you read robert
mussels the man without qualities yeah i
read that back in grad school i had a
girlfriend who was like super into
muscle and so she recommended it
i can't say that i rec i remember an
awful lot about it
mark uh
glad to see you here too as well i
recently read shakespeare's the tempest
thought prospero was an interesting
representation
of the distinction between the
contemplative and political life than he
thought
been way too long since i read it
so and actually i think i saw it
about a decade ago
more than a decade ago because it was at
fayetteville state university
so i don't really remember enough about
it to to have thoughts
um
brian how should shakespeare be taught
in high school where people are most
likely to be introduced to him should
teachers focus more on the tragedies the
comedies the mix of the two i don't know
i'm
i'm not a lit person i'm not a
shakespeare scholar
i just became happy that he gets in
there at all you know
and i think we had shakespeare in in
high school in some of our lit classes
but frankly i was such a bad student
that i don't remember what we did i
would bring in my own books and read
them in class and and kind of you know i
would take these honors classes because
like when you had a grade point average
an a would count as a five instead of a
four a b would count as a four instead
of a three and i would shoot for like
getting b's
um
and that that way i could keep my mom
off my back i was not a good student at
all
you know i had no intention of going to
college
i was going to go in the army and then
either like become a lifer
or get out and become a mercenary
because i had a friend whose uncle was a
mercenary
and i you know just like partying and
uh
doing stuff getting in fights you know
dating stuff like that so you know
good example i was a bright kid and they
put shakespeare in front of me but i
didn't read shakespeare because they
told me to so i you know i don't know
that's gonna
do that much uh abradon has a funny
remark here reading celeb is like
talking to that odd uncle at family
reunions yeah
uh
short definition of post-modernism there
isn't one and anybody who gives one to
you is full of crap so you know
i wouldn't worry about that uh avarose
what is the best part of you according
to you best part according to you in
aristotle's philosophy
there isn't the best part i mean
why would there be there it depends on
what you're looking for he's got a book
on metaphysics there's a lot of
metaphysics in the physics he's got some
great stuff on ethics that you put
together with the rhetoric and the
politics and poetics and got a really
cool coherent hole there along with
topics book three he's got logical works
why why would we have to have a best you
know
um
alexander more for non-philosophy
question were you ever a fan of thrash
metal i was a fan of the og thrash metal
um
you know i got into metallica when they
were good
um and i i count that as going all the
way up to the injustice for all although
that was terribly mixed
as uh
um
hatfield and uh uh ulrich um admit to
they always they they treated newstead
poorly they didn't they didn't make
good use of him
um so i yeah i loved early metallica i
was super into mega death i liked
anthrax
um you know i didn't never got into
slayer i always thought
there was something about him i didn't
like
by by contrast though i really enjoyed
metal church
uh and there were other thrash bands as
well
so yeah um
i don't listen to like a lot of
contemporary stuff although we're going
to hear a new band that i haven't heard
before
at summerfest this year and i don't
remember their name offhand
um
dan h can we get any high school doctor
sadler photos people already have a long
time ago i mean what what do you think
is
uh in my facebook uh um
profile and page
there's the ones that i have i don't
have an awful lot of photos
unfortunately and you know i've posted
some stuff in quora from time to time
you can see on my sadler's stories
there's like a shot of me in high school
when i was getting muscular and stuff so
there's plenty of them out there
um
mark wildcard what's the weirdest
question you've been asked in one of
these amas
i don't know i'd have to go because i've
been i i looked recently i've been doing
these
since
what like 2014.
um
i should go back through some of these
and see what what some of the super
oddball
questions are maybe put them together in
a video you know along with the answers
uh white crow's veganism a moral
responsibility i personally believe yes
we talked about this at the top of the
hour no it's not a it's not a moral
responsibility you know the moral
responsibility is to reduce
animal suffering
and um not to be a dick about it and
unfortunately most vegans still today
are kind of dicks
you know
about that jb bell i got into metallica
when they're still good so you know
people don't don't
know this right cliff burton was really
important in early metallica after
they picked him up
after dave mustain was kicked out
because dave mustaine wrote some of the
early material and cliff burton was
really really central and then he died
they replaced him with jason neustead
they did garage days re-revisited um
which was quite good you know a bunch of
covers
um then they did an inju and justice for
all which
probably the thrashiest of their their
albums
um we listened to that a lot when i was
in the army
and then i remember when the black album
came out i was i i knew this kid who i
had tutored and he like you got to hear
this it's the new metallica and he
started playing it for me and i was like
what the hell is this crap this i mean i
recognize the singer
i i get what's going on but
this is kind of light crap you know
they've lost their way and from that
point on i just i wasn't interested in
where they were going you know
um
ahmed best argument on infinite universe
i don't have any um
christian good latin american
philosophers if any
i don't know i mean i i'm not i'm not uh
somebody who works on latin american
philosophy so i i wouldn't be
i could say like you know a couple names
but i haven't actually read their stuff
you know
um
colomous suggests borja so i guess we
could consider borges a philosopher
right
i'm sir do you enjoy any video games
i used to but i don't have the time for
playing video games
um
constance do you see any connection
between the psychoanalysis of a young
and a freud in the ancient philosophers
the greeks especially in terms of what
is human nature
no and i wouldn't try to force any
connection i mean obviously freud and
young have read ancient philosophy
um but you know people like to
schematize these things and i don't
think that's that's useful
uh shrey do you think plants have life
and by extension feel pain as well as a
legit counter against veganism or
vegetarians
wow i i don't get into that sort of
stuff at all you know i mean if if you
want to be a vegetarian or vegan and you
want to talk about like you could just
already focus on animal suffering how
much does plant
uh agriculture impose suffering on the
worms and shrews and mice and all this
other stuff
plants don't have a lot of
sensation if they do have any you know
dan while reading the symposium what
would you recommend as a wine
whatever you like i'm not a wine person
you know
uh jb echoes do a weirdest ama video
yeah that would be that would be good
uh nate thoughts on the films of inga
igmar bergman
[Music]
i mean i've watched some of them i'm not
a film person like i said
aryan says thanks for the suggestion
can't wait to learn western philosophy
some indian philosophies as i'm from
nepal that's good yeah and i'm sure
there's people out there that are doing
good work in indian philosophy all right
we're a little bit past the top of the
the time and i i've got to get some some
food in me before i have to do my
philosophy chat for patreon supporters
in a bit uh imser opinions on jung not
into young definitely not into jungians
i like reading jung because he's a good
writer and stylist but i think stuff
like the collective unconscious and
archetypes i just find that's kind of
stuff silly
um
abdren uh recom is talking about some
thoughts concerning education which i
read decades ago
uh he recommended cyanica and cicero as
essential reading yeah okay
uh so appalled so this is the last one
i'll take because then i got to go do
you believe there's objective grounds
for an ethical system depends on what
you mean by objective grounds you know
whenever we use these abstract terms we
got to be we got to be a little bit more
concrete specifying what we mean about
that sort of stuff
not necessarily in a sense of a natural
law but more of rational necessity i
don't know what rational necessity means
um
i mean i think that there's we don't
need objective grounds we we can just
like say this actually seems to make
sense and let's apply it and by the way
you notice that a lot of ethical systems
lots and lots of overlap right remember
that meme when it showed like
deontology virtue ethics utilitarianism
what do you do in the time of covid
mask up stay home get vast right
um they're all they'd all be
recommending the same thing you know
don't act like an [ __ ] you know uh i
mean
there's an awful lot of overlap between
ethical systems and i don't i don't know
that we need objective grounds for them
i i i'd actually be kind of suspect of
of people who
use that language a lot because
you know if they're waiting for that
before they decide to be a decent person
and engage in personal development and
like you know make hard decisions
that might be a problem so that's a
fitting place to end um thanks for
everybody who for coming and asking your
questions and
um i'll think about doing that you know
like weirdest question video that could
be kind of a cool thing to do right now
i got to get
my summer class up and running and some
other commitments
met before i could do interesting
projects like that but
all right i'll see everybody and uh
oh i do want to mention uh tomorrow we
got another live streaming thing
uh you know we've been talking about the
stoic virtues we've got the virtue of
temperance tomorrow same same time
same deal you know ask questions get
answers
and then
the next sunday after that i'm going to
have a free class on light hall going
over five more stoic practices from
epictetus's and caribbean i put actually
put the link
in the description to this video
um and uh so that that should be fun as
well
so i'll see all of you and catch you
somewhere else